[vent qui souffle]
Ce nouveau Hand Spinner ne fonctionne pas du tout...! [rires]
Bonjour à vous tous !
Et bienvenue dans cette douzième vidéo du calendrier de l'Avent. On est pile poil à la moitié.
Comme tous les jours, une vidéo à 6H du matin.
Aujourd'hui je vous présente un jeu, je vous parle d'un jeu
que j'aime particulièrement aussi, et comme par hasard, c'est un jeu que j'aime beaucoup et qui est de la même marque
que le jeu dont je vous ai parlé le 3 décembre dernier,
c'est-à-dire de chez Yellow, ça s'appelle "Time Bombe",
c'est une tuerie entre amis !
Vous savez j'ai créé un jeu qui s'appelle "Menteur Menteur", dont le lien est aussi dans la description d'ailleurs,
qui est un jeu de bluffe entre amis,
là aussi il y a beaucoup de bluffe.
Et ce n'est pas du tout le même principe, mais il y a le même mood de chercher qui ment, qui te cache quelque chose...
"Time Bombe", ça ressemble à ça.
Et je vais vous raconter l'histoire.
L'histoire c'est que Moriarty a mis une bombe dans Big Ben.
Et cette bombe va exploser à un moment donné.
Il y a donc 2 équipes: celle des "méchants" menée par Moriarty,
qui veulent absolument que cette bombe explose,
et celle des gentils: celle de Sherlock Holmes.
Sauf que tout le monde, va se faire passer pour un membre de l'équipe de Sherlock Holmes,
pour désamorcer la bombe.
Et dedans il y a les méchants, mais personne ne sait qui sont les méchants.
Même pas eux entre eux.
Donc il faut qu'ils puissent entre eux, durant le jeu, déterminer aussi qui est leur collègue (ou pas), pour faire exploser cette bombe.
Pour la désamorcer, c'est très simple.
On a tous des câbles. (Je vous la fait simplement...)
On a tous des câbles et à chaque tour, on va aller couper un câble chez quelqu'un.
Et cette personne va essayer de nous dire: "Attention, pas moi, j'ai des câbles qui vont faire péter la bombe..."
"Attention, moi j'ai deux bons câbles à désamorcer..." (etc...)
Et c'est très vite le bordel.
C'est-à-dire, dès le début, une fois que les cartes sont distribuées
tout le monde commence par dire: "-Moi je suis un gentil !"
-Ouais, moi aussi !
"-Moi aussi !"
Ce qui ne marche pas.
Et c'est à vous de déterminer, par les questions.
C'est que du blabla quoi !
C'est du forcing, c'est du bluffe, pour réussir à faire exploser la bombe ou pas.
Ca se joue sous la forme d'un jeu de cartes.
Parmis lesquelles on va trouver des câbles qu'il ne faut pas couper, parce qu'ils font exploser Big Ben.
Des câbles qui ne servent à rien...
Et des câbles qui désamorcent la bombe.
Et il y en a 8 en tout a désamorcer au cours de la partie.
L'équipe des méchants est rouge.
L'équipe des gentils est bleue.
Ca c'est très classique.
Ashtag: pourquoi toujours les rouges pour les méchants...
A cause du communisme mon ami !
Et ça se joue à partir de 4 joueurs.
A 4 joueurs c'est possible.
Alors, dans le challenge, il y a quelque chose qu'il faut faire quand vous jouez à 4 joueurs,
C'est, quand vous allez distribuer les rôles de qui est gentil, et qui est méchant,
Vous préparez 3 gentils et 2 méchants,
vous mélangez, vous distribuez ça aux 4 joueurs,
et donc il y a une carte qui reste de côté.
Ca pimente un peu le jeu.
Comme ça, on ne sait pas si il y a 1 ou 2 méchants dans la partie.
Mais le format idéal, celui où l'on rit le plus je trouve, c'est 5 joueurs et 6 joueurs.
Comme d'habitude, je vous mets le lien de ça dans la description.
Dans laquelle vous retrouverez d'autres idées cadeaux, comme mon livre si ça vous tente,
les places pour l'Olympia, des informations diverses, diverses, que même peut être variées.
N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo si ce n'est pas encore fait.
A vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait non plus.
Peut-être à me parler de vos parties "Time Bombe", si vous connaissiez déjà le jeu,
c'est vraiment un très très bon jeu entre potos.
Et rendez-vous demain à 6H !
Ciao !
[musique]